.
PETER DOOCY, LIVE IN THE NORTH
LAWN, PETER, THANKS.
WE HAVE SOME STARTLING,
EXCLUSIVE IMAGES TONIGHT FROM
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE IMAGES,
MASS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
THOUSANDS OF THEM ASSEMBLING
ALONG ONE KEY ENTRY POINT.
THE NUMBERS ARE REALLY
STAGGERING AND ACCORDING TO THE
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL THE
FACT THAT VIRTUALLY NONE OF THEM
ARE VACCINATE AND THEY ARE NOW
SETTING UP AS YOU SEE HERE A AT
THE PRESENT TIME CITY UNDER A
BRIDGE IS CONCERNING TO
AUTHORITIES THERE.
CORRESPONDENT REPORTS FROM DEL
RIO, TEXAS.
>> FOX NEWS IS GETTING EXCLUSIVE
LOOK AT THE DETERIORATING
SITUATION O. AN LOT BORDER HERE
IN DEL RIO TEXAS AND THE FOOTAGE
IS STUNNING.
CLOSE TO 11,000 MIGRANTS ALL
CRAMMED UNDER THE INTERNATIONAL
BRIDGE, WAITING TO BE PROCESSED
BY A COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED
BORDER PATROL.
SOME ALREADY BUILDING MAKESHIFT
SHELTERS OUT OF GRASS AND
STICKS.
OTHERS ERECTING TENTS, A
MAJORITY OF THESE MIGRANTS FROM
HAITI, WHICH HAS A COVID
VACCINATION RATE OF UNDER 1%.
FROM THE AIR, WE WATCHED AS A
CONSTANT STREAM OF HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE LEFT MEXICO BY CROSSING A
DAM IN THE RIO GRANDE AND WALKED
ILLEGALLY INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
MASSES OF THEM GATHERING ON THE
SHORE AFTER THEY CROSSED.
FROM THERE, WE COULD SEE A
LENGTHY LINE OF MIGRANTS WALKING
A DIRT PATH TOWARDS THE
INTERNATIONAL BRIDGE WHERE THEY
WILL JOINT CONSTANTLY GROWING
MASS OF PEOPLE THERE.
NEARBY A BULLDOZER CLEARS A
FIELD, APPARENTLY MAKING SPACE
FOR POTENTIAL EMERGENCY SHELTERS
OR MAYBE A PROCESSING TENT.
SOURCES ON THE GROUND SENT US
VIDEO THE SITUATION FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE AS HUNDREDS OF
MIGRANTS CROSSED ILLEGALLY INTO
THE U.S. WITHOUT ANY RESISTANCE
ON EITHER SIDE OF THE BORDER
WITH MORE IN WAIT ON THE MEXICAN
SIDE OF THE RIVER AND IT HAPPENS
ALL DAY LONG.
THE DEL RIO MAYOR, A DEMOCRAT,
DECLARING A LOCAL STATE OF
DISASTER AS A RESULT.
>> THERE IS PEOPLE HAVING BABIES
DOWN THERE.
THERE IS PEOPLE COLLAPSING OUT
OF THE HEAT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
CHALLENGING TO DESCRIBE IN WORDS
BUT IT'S EXTREMELY CHAOTIC.
>> BRET, LAST NIGHT WE LEARNED
THAT THE FAA HAD SUDDENLY ISSUED
A TFR, A TEMPORARY FLIGHT
RESTRICTION IN THE AREA AROUND
THE BRIDGE RIGHT HERE.
WHAT THAT MEANT WAS THAT OUR FOX
NEWS DRONE COULD NO LONGER FLY
IN THE AREA AND BRING EVERYBODY
THOSE IMAGES OF THE MIGRANTS
UNDER THE BRIDGE.
AT THE TIME THE FAA SAID IT WAS
FOR A SPECIAL SECURITY REASON.
WELL, I'M HAPPY TO GIVE AN
UPDATE TODAY, THIS MORNING FOX
NEWS FILED A WAIVER WITH THE FAA
TO TRY TO GET OUR DRONE BACK IN
THE AIR.
HAPPY TO REPORT THE FAA CLEARED
US THIS AFTERNOON.
WE HAVE BEEN GIVEN CLEARANCE TO
FLY OUR DRONE ONCE AGAIN HERE AT
THE BRIDGE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO IN THE
COMING DAYS.
WE WILL SEND IT BACK TO Y